the managing editor in legendary
broadcaster himself of Eason Brent
Musburger here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Brent I am fine rich you
excited me running down how much is at
stake this weekend this is going to be
some weekend in the National Football
League my friend I'll tell you and I'd
even have to tell you we're looking live
anywhere either and I know we'll be
looking live at the black hole you know
what I say in here how are you by
playing I'm doing great do you think
this is the last Raiders game in the
black hole right you know I honestly
don't know
rich obviously there's a there's a
strong possibility simply because of
what Mark Davis has said in the past if
the City of Oakland I decided to go
ahead and and make its lawsuit there are
options in the Bay Area I don't think
there's any possibility that they can
come in to Las Vegas a year early really
Boyd Stadium is far far from an NFL
standard not even as good as the StubHub
Center where the Chargers have played so
I don't think they're coming here but
the other options certainly down at
Santa Clara they could share with the
49ers down there they could go to AT&T
with the San Francisco Giants play
baseball there have been football games
played in there not ideal but it's
certainly available Berkeley not too far
and that again if they need to go on the
road for every home game you still got
the city of San Diego in the City of
Glendale Arizona were the where the
Cardinals play site but the door the
door has to be left slightly ajar simply
because of logistics and what the
Raiders face with all the employees in
the in the Oakland area not to mention
the fans and those that have been so
loyal to the Oakland bran despite two
moves one of course that was laid down
to Los Angeles in the second impending
one over to the new stadium in Las Vegas
as I understand the law a law firm came
to the City of Oakland and took it on a
consent a they would not charge per our
contingency as the word
crowds and they would take a percentage
of whatever they could extract from the
Raiders in the NFL now as a total
outsider do not have a law degree my
feeling would be that the NFL would
suffer losses on the west coast in the
California courts but if they decided to
say we're going to go the distance on
this one because these are private
businesses and we can move to wherever
we want one once leases are up the
Supreme Court's it's very very much in
the background on this settlement and as
we all know now it's a far more
conservative court than it has been in
some time but the NFL may feel we don't
want to go the distance we're going to
tie up too much money we're gonna have
spent too much time on this we'll pay
the City of Oakland off and and maybe
that's what the lawyers are counting on
I you know like I said I don't have a
law degree I'm just watching this from
afar I disappointed the City of Oakland
I think it's a long shot for them if the
NFL decides to go to the distance
spending as much time as I have in the
Oakland area the the most underrated
aspect of the Raiders the fan base they
have been terrific to deal with it's a
heavy Hispanic crowd a lot of women I
spent time with a lot of those fans and
Families they've been great
they have been obviously abused through
the decades by this team but many of
them saying to me we're gonna go to Las
Vegas we're gonna follow the team down
there and many of them have already
bought season tickets so we shall we
shall see what happens I do not want to
close the door and and the other thing
rich and I want to point out is it I
hope the media doesn't jump to the
conclusion and say this is the last
night because when they did that in
Cleveland when they Brown original
Browns moved to Baltimore there was
basically a riot in the old Municipal
Stadium and we don't want to see
anything like that on on Monday that
will just let let those in charge of the
Raiders decide where they're gonna spend
next season for their home games before
they make the move to
Las Vegas right Musburger here on the
Rich Eisen show we all know what the
Bears look like and we suppose they
wouldn't be looking like they look
without Khalil Mack they're the Cowboys
have absolutely become a different team
with Amari Cooper on their roster heart
of hearts quiet moment do you think Jon
Gruden has any regrets about those
situations Brent well I'm sure that you
know he was back in wish that he had
both of them playing for him Monday
night against Denver but and and some of
it was financial when it came to Khalil
Mack it was also the same agent
represented both and obviously there was
some animosity which flowed I think the
agent was determined to try and get the
players out of error I don't personally
second-guess the Amari Cooper trade
I've known Maury since he was down in
Alabama and I just thought it was not
happy whenever I was around in Oakland
very quiet
I didn't seem to like talking small talk
with people like me and I just I said
you know it's a far different person
than I knew in Tuscaloosa and and I'm
happy that he's played well perfect
talent I cannot speak for Khalil Mack
because I didn't cover him personally
but everybody has told me he was a
terrific kid and he's one of the
obviously one of the best defensive
players in the UH in the national in the
National Football League and and
certainly the defensive coaches of the
Raiders wish that they'd had him around
I think last time I checked rich he had
more sacks as an individual than the
Raider defense does yeah overall it's
been very tough for the Raider defense
to to settle down and get anything going
that the tackling has not been good the
angles taken by the defensive backs long
long process to get it up to speed but
but Gooden manages to always sort of
take an optimistic look at things he
knows it is what it is he's done a very
good job with Derek Carr that
relationship has improved obviously I
don't expect this team to be contending
for the Super Bowl even next year but
they should be able to take some big
steps toward him
provement with those three first rounds
they can obviously trade one or two down
and add even more craft choices to
accumulate some young talent going
forward the team itself has been good to
be around the players seem to enjoy each
other
they've been conversational I don't know
what they'll show up with on Monday
night simply because the offensive line
was so beaten up last week in Cincinnati
two new cards were in there the tackles
had a tough time so we'll see and from
all I hear the Bronco is apparently are
gonna undergo a head coaching change
next year it looks like so you never
know about the athletes what what the
Broncos will come up with sure looks
that way Brent Musburger here on the
Rich Eisen show which team or teams do
your guys in the desert you are sensing
a lot of folks are really falling in
love with for the Super Bowl this year
New Orleans Saints have been have been
the pick almost all along rich in the in
the NFC and view that home-field
advantage down there they they know that
through paris' plays much better down in
the dome than he has certainly this year
on the road there was a lot of there was
a lot of backing of the Rams
because we have a lot of Southern
California folks coming in here bet on
their favorite team spend time at the
shows enjoy themselves in Las Vegas and
that's been a very very big
disappointment the way that they have
sort of fallen on hard times in the in
the last couple of weeks originally
there was a lot a lot of backing of the
Kansas City but now they're questions
about that defense going forward the
flavor of the week actually has been the
Los Angeles chargers they just have
viewed how they were able to come back
under Philip Rivers they get things done
he has got an awful lot of weapons once
mike williams of clemson stepped up and
shook off the injuries he's got tyrone
williams in there
he's also got Travis Benjamin with
Alessi and 20 up gates certainly is not
the player that he once was he's a Hall
of Famer and he's pretty good
eight nine yard pass Philip Rivers I've
seen him twice in person I've been
fascinated watching him he really takes
charge
onions illusion he's certainly a
hall-of-famer in my eyes that's a very
good football team tough defense
I didn't head coach there has done an
outstanding job with the Chargers going
forward I believe that although I do
think that on your network on Saturday
they're gonna have the hands full the
Chargers are in the playoffs and that's
what motivates aquire most of all Ravens
have not yet locked up a spot so they're
going to come in with that defense and a
lot of motivation we don't know if
Jackson can handle this going forward on
the road but he's been phenomenal I saw
him in person against the writers the
running attack for the Ravens
outstanding and we shall see how we
shall see what happens few more minutes
left here with Brent Musburger here on
the Rich Eisen show how do you view the
national championship race right now
Oklahoma Alabama and obviously Clemson
and Notre Dame Alabama
I think it's Alabama and Clemson in the
in the final rich to tell you the truth
simply based on defense
Kyle marinas is just a phenomenal talent
but you know the Heisman Trophy actually
added a little motivation to the Crimson
Tide as if that talent ever needs it but
there were some teammates of torti who
weeded out immediately afterwards we'll
see on the 29th of December I am I am
really happy that they got off New
Year's and they're gonna go week from
Saturday with both of the semifinals I
think that the viewing public is better
served by that you know New Year's Eve
belongs to families and wives and people
go out and they could never let me get
the corner turned I think - very
interesting games I would not look over
Notre Dame I think the Brian Kelly I'm
glad the the administration kept him on
after that bad season that he had a
couple years back they'll play hard
comes in just has too many NFL
first-round draft choices on that
defense I think for the the Irish to
sustain their offense and then I look
for Alabama to to take charge of our
Cuyler Murray that'll be a very
obviously Oklahoma's not going to be
shut down they're gonna they have the
ability to score on any team and they
will but I think in the end as long as
two ''tis ankle is good and I watched
practice when they allow the cameras in
for a few minutes and he was moving
around quite well so I I look here
Clemson Alabama fine I'll go with the
chalk in those two games you know I keep
thinking again Brent there should be an
18 playoff I mean there should be a
playoff game tonight
there should be a round a quarterfinal
game tonight there should be a couple
over this weekend there should be a
Christmas Eve and I know you're calling
a game Monday night we should have won
on Monday and we should get it done I
think your town in Vegas would be lit if
something like that happens the whole
country would be locked in it's time for
a teams do you would you agree with that
assessment I agree with everything you
just said and I believe it's on its way
if you look at the history of the
especially the NBA even the NFL for that
matter but in say in the NHL a playoffs
don't shrink they grow because the fans
like him in every winner of one of the
five major conferences deserves a chance
to go forward people said oh you'll
diminish the regular season I adamantly
disagree with that because attempting to
win even the pac-12 which was put down
early would have brought a lot of
attention to the conference who's going
to get into the playoff then you have a
team like Central Florida the best of
the group of five they should make it
and then let a committee choose a couple
of at-large teams going forward and then
have the quarterfinals I really believe
that these home campuses listen the NFL
has proven conclusively that these home
field sites that's the fans they don't
have to pay money to travel during the
holiday seasons they've got their team
at home add so much to the community and
the colleges should get back to those
communities like Tuscaloosa and Columbus
and Los Angeles when USC is playing well
I adamantly agree with what you're
saying I think it's just a matter of
time and they'll have more than one
television network involved they'll have
two
the National Football League they have
proved it going through the college's
should not be stubborn you can still
keep a very good bowl season going for
some of these teams an award but they're
not good enough to play for the national
championship
yeah it doesn't fit the bad boy mowers
Gasparilla bowl of last night Brent you
know I'm saying easily we just talked
about you know I like to tell people let
me tell you having been around the NFL
because we're doing the radio much
closer to these teams and these rosters
there's so many youngsters who you don't
know about in college football Tiger
planes and there are so many seniors
never ever play in the National Football
League they deserve a little bit of a
reward if they could or warm-weather
City and have themselves a full game if
most of us don't watch Soviet there will
be plenty of folks that do when so if so
it's a great reward but I do certainly
believe in what you're saying let's
let's have an a-team playoff sooner
rather than later before I let you go
Brent Musburger there's been a fun game
on the internet this week where you
create your own Bowl game name by taking
the last place you shopped and then the
last food you ate and add the word Bowl
and that's your bowl game what would
that be for you brent musburger lee's
discount liquor bowl what did you eat
something there so the least discount
liquor no I I would take it in and out
burger with me okay so so you're both
your bowl game would be the Lee's
discount liquor in and out burger bowl
that's it
that's it my friend fantastic you take
care of yourself Brent happy New Year to
you Sam you and all your great viewers
and you do a great job and we'll talk to
you come 2019 my friend look forward to
it Brent Happy New Year to you and yours
again he'll be calling the Raiders and
Broncos and the Raiders final season
game in Kansas City which could be
absolutely huge Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience